[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
good day walter hi martin we're back
yes no i don't know where have we been
gone
yeah we're continuing our talk
on pope francis now martin
perhaps people must realize that this is
almost like a
mini series within the what's up
series yeah because it's important we
we couldn't do it in just one lecture
because there's so many other aspects
that i have to get together
and we have to cover as much as we can
to do it as complete as con
yes and it always takes us through the
history
to the present day that's the important
thing
to show that nothing has changed this is
not a
new concept this is a fulfillment
of an old concept in fact it's a
fulfillment of prophecy correct correct
so
we will be doing this one and probably
one more
and then the series will be and then we
can move on to another topic again
yes excellent so let's pray
our heavenly father thank you very much
for bringing us together again
we ask that you please bless and
enlighten our minds
and keep the enemy away from us in jesus
name
amen amen i don't think
many people realize how deep the
deception runs
and i remember years ago when
i did the total onslaught series
there were people that said that this
this cannot be
this is in the realms of conspiracy
theories
but you know if you look at the data
then unfortunately it's conspiracy facts
correct because they say it themselves
it's just
one quote after the other exactly and
that's what we're trying to do here too
we're trying to show that this is not
something
that we make up or that we conjecture
this is the reality
correct and this is something that
is described in prophecy
both in the bible and in the spirit of
prophecy
and we have to do we have to work
through this reality
in order to understand what we're up
against
and it's important for our decision
making capacity
yes because a lot of people can't seem
to see that the mark of the beast
is busy being worked out in the
background
absolutely it's it's stealthfully coming
forward
yes and they also can't see that rome
has never changed
correct they think it has changed
because the noises that you hear
are so different to what they expect and
that's why it's so important to bring
all of this together
yes so many people say you know this is
a 19th century philosophy
and it should be updated yes now you
cannot
update the word of god there are people
that want to
update it but you can't update the word
of god
because it is a fixed
beacon it's like a rock that cannot be
moved
and in that light we need to continue
this to show
some more ramifications and we'll try
and tie it together
and see where it leads yes and this
episode
a lot of people will probably cry
conspiracy theory
well they must enjoy themselves the
facts will
talk talk for themselves so
understanding
francis nothing is as it seems
we're going to talk about knighthood
today martin
because there are many nights in the
world
not in terms of darkness well maybe also
in terms of darkness
but we want to know where these
knighthoods come from and what this
chivalry movement
is all about so let's have a look
at some definitions
the order of knighthood the institution
of knighthood
stems from the holy orders that the
catholic church
established in the middle ages that's
very important
correct it has a catholic
church origin yes and now we find
knighthoods of course in the protestant
world
but that is not as it seems
correct the roots are somewhere else
the roots are somewhere else and the
plants
that come from the roots are still from
the same origin
they might call themselves protestant
but that is a sham
the word order from the latin ordo
then meant a closed circle
the members of which were bound by
certain obligations and swore to observe
a set of rules during the crusades the
rules governing monastic
orders were extended to the soldiers
who once in the holy land established
various religious military orders
to ensure the safety of the pilgrims and
the sick
and to further the battle for
christianity
some of the most renowned medieval
orders of
knighthood were the templars the
hospitals
and the order of teutonic knights
now some of them we will find in the
protestant world as well
like the hospitals of saint john and we
can talk about those
a little bit in a moment but
they are as far removed from
protestantism
as the east is from the west
here's another web page that talks about
the knighthood ceremony
the ceremony of knighthood usually took
place during one of the great feasts for
instance
christmas or easter on the eve of the
ceremony
the squire would take a ritual bath
and be dressed in a piece of white
clothing
symbolizing purity there's even an
order which is called the order of the
bath
of which prince charles is the grand
master correct
it's one of the highest orders in
correct the squire wore over this
a red robe a sign of his nobility
the squire's attire was completed by a
pair of black shoes symbolizing
death the squire would then spend the
rest of the night in silent
prayer in the chapel of the castle or a
church
the accolade known also as dubbing
or edubent took place on the following
morning
this was a ceremony during which the
knighthood was conferred onto the squire
the ceremony began with mass so it's a
very
catholic order yes during which the
priest would typically give a sermon
about the duties and responsibilities of
a knight
a sword and a shield which had been
blessed by a priest would then be
brought forward by the squire's sponsor
and given to the lord conducting the
ceremony
after being presented to the lord the
squire took his vows
and swore allegiance to his lord
now martin we have to be quite clear on
this
this is not the lord god that they're
swearing allegiance to
this is an earthly individual yes
and again scripturally the bible says
call no one
lord or master correct so
these these ordinances are not in the
order of the bible
in fact they are contrary to that
the vows taken by the would-be knight
reflected
the code of chivalry amongst other
things he swore to be loyal to his lord
to be devoted to the church to defend
the weak
to show generosity to the poor and to
always speak the truth
i wonder whether that is necessarily so
because if you go to the jesuit order
then a lie spoken to further the ends of
the church
would be permissible right and there you
swear
allegiance to an earthly lord the jesuit
general
yeah and lyola said that even if god
gave you a
dog as a as a
general you would have to obey him
completely and if he says something is
white that's black then you will say
that it is white
to break this earth would be to commit a
crime against
god and any night who did so would face
divine retribution
and eternal damnation now all of these
things
are not in the order of god so what are
they doing
in the world because if we go to james
chapter 5
verse 12 it says but above all things my
brethren swear not
neither by heaven neither by the earth
neither by any other oath
but let your yea be yea and your nay
be nay lest ye fall into condemnation
so this is directly against the bible
correct because they were
swearing to the lord a lord
yes which in any case they're not
allowed to do
correct you know this verse is often
stretched beyond
its original meaning saying that you
can't promise that something is the
truth for example like in a court of law
uh there you are just saying yes let my
yeah be the end my name so help you god
i will do the best that i can to tell
the truth and nothing but the truth
but basically you're not allowed to
swear by
anything that is
of this realm so you cannot swear
allegiance to a person what if that
person is an apostate yes
or becomes an apostate even a good
person
rather make your oath to god and leave
it at that
now these initiations ceremonies
count for the nobility right
and there are various orders and just to
show
that even the queen of england and the
royalty of
england are initiated into orders
and there's a druid order and she was
initiated queen elizabeth into this
order when she was still young
and and these files are available on
their pages
so this is not a conspiracy right let's
have a look at that
the sound is poor because it's old
but let's look
[Music]
foreign
so martin there are many other orders of
course into which they are also
initiated now it's interesting that in
the course of history
they removed her from
these ranks because of
language barriers he couldn't speak well
correct
but it's interesting that the sun is the
prince of wales all right
the male online in 2019
gave this article druid strip queen of
an
ancient honorary title she gained as a
princess because she doesn't speak
welsh as a 20 year old princess
elizabeth was invested as honorary overt
of the bards of
wales at the national i stedford in
1946.
she dressed up in green robes and an
ancient sword was passed over ahead
as she was given the bardic name
elizabeth
or windsor it was part of a move to
affiliate the royal family more closely
with wales at the time when nationalism
was
on the rise well we don't have to go
into the details but it's obviously an
like a knighthood the same kind of
ritual
now what is always interesting to me
is the type of people that are actually
knighted now remember when you become a
knight
it is a military action because a knight
is a warrior
and he wheels the sword on behalf
of the church
now if you martin were to
choose were the people
to bring into some guild
whatever if you were that way inclined
let's put it that way
it not being a biblical concept
what kind of person would you bring into
a christian
institution well one that at least
adheres to the bible i see so would you
bring
all kinds of people that set examples
in in drugs and witchcraft and
satanism would you bring those into the
church and make them nights
it will go against the church so i don't
think so no because
if you just look at the requirements for
becoming an elder or deacon
you're absolutely right okay so
this is a very interesting thing now
remember
that catholicism has
a religion that is for public
consumption
and then there is a inner religion which
is for the elite for the inner circle
so nothing is as it seems
so just by looking at who
receives a knighthood now the fact that
the queen
is very active in handing out
knighthoods
should not deceive us because the crown
yes is subject to rome correct
the crown is only on her head like a
lease
yes it belongs to someone else
exactly because the crown was seeded
to the vatican so she actually just
does these things on behalf of the owner
of the crown
correct and to the world it seems like
something that is done within
the royal and protestant realm
but nothing could be further from the
truth
so let's have a look at some of the
people
that have been knighted in the world
and i mean if you look at this picture i
think everybody should recognize that
that could be
mick jagger right yes
and these people with their rock band
were pretty blatant about who they
believed in
as their source let's go no further than
that and they wrote
many many songs pleased to meet you
and even sympathy yes sympathy with the
devil
so let's have a look
here you have the members of the beatles
for example
paul mccartney one of them not long
after his producer george martin got the
nod
paul mccartney was knighted by his queen
in 1997
for services to music
now let's just stop there when you get
knighted it is a catholic order
you get knighted for service to your
lord
yes all right not knighted for
music united for service to the lord
now which lord would use
music that propagates drugs mellow
yellow
and all sergeant peppers and
all of these things which one
would you be serving then right correct
not the
biblical one proud to be british
wonderful day
and it's long way from little terrace in
liverpool the rock legend said
on his day of distinction
and he's making certain signs which to
some would seem
innocuous and then you have
sir elton john having already become a
commander of the british empire
elton john was knighted by queen
elizabeth ii
in 1998 for both his music and his
charity work
involving aids and the lgbt community
the man born reginald dwight is now sir
elton hercules john not bad
well these people are all role models in
the world
yeah all right yeah let's just leave it
at that
here you have in 2007
bono the u2 singer was named an honorary
knight by queen elizabeth ii
for his musical and charitable work
although she didn't carry out the
ceremony because of bono's
irish citizenship he received the honor
from
ambassador david redaway in dublin
now here's a man that has been known
to swing upside down crosses
and all kinds of things over his
audience
and already we've spoken about sir
mick jagger these are all interesting
people that have received
knighthoods then you have
rod stewart veteran singer rod stewart
became knighted in 2016 ceremony that
was led by prince william
the former faces leader was honored for
his musical
and charitable contributions
then you have sir von morrison although
the former them
front man is irish he's from belfast in
northern ireland part of the united
kingdom and so in 2016 he was
reintroduced as sir ivan morrison
after being knighted by prince charles
for his contributions to music and
tourism
in northern ireland so let's just look
at some more detail
here's a another page that explains some
of these things being honored by the
queen
isn't exactly new for legendary british
musicians
but there are levels to these
distinctions rendering
rock stars who have been knighted as a
class unto themselves
all the way back in 1965 the beatles
were awarded
mbes member of the most excellent order
of the british empire for their
services to entertainment
in more recent years other famous
figures such as
sting eric clapton roger daltry
robert plant have been awarded the
slightly more prestigious
obe officer of and
cbe commander of distinctions for their
musical contributions only a select few
however have been granted the status of
knight
of the british empire by queen elizabeth
which includes the sword ceremony
plenty of pomp and circumstances and the
distinction
of being called sir as long as you are a
citizen
of the united kingdom while a variety of
artists actors scientists
and other figures of note have become
serves
or in the case of a female resist
recipients
dames knighted rockers are an
extremely exclusive group
if some fans have their way the list
keeps growing
there are ongoing campaigns to bestow
knighthoods on jimmy page
brian may though respective guitarists
for led zeppelin
and queen have yet to reach the final
stage
now martin let's have a look at some of
these
with a little bit of a lens yes
bob dylan bob dylan to receive u.s
equivalent of a knighthood so it's not
only the queen
that is involved here bob dylan is said
to be presented with the presidential
medal of freedom by u.s leader barack
obama
the award is the highest honor a
civilian can gain
and is the u.s equivalent of a
knighthood
in the past it has been given to the
likes of mother teresa
and stephen hawking the award-giving
ceremony will take place this spring
reports
holy moly so we need to
understand who is actually
receiving a knighthood and for what
purpose yes but martin what what people
don't understand is that there
is a level because nothing is as it
seems
here are people who are being knighted
who
have quite blatantly and openly
proclaimed to the world who
they serve who their ultimate lord is
so let's look at some of these and they
use an acronym
for the devil which
is rain man so when you hear them
say rain man or when you hear them
blatantly say who their allegiance is to
you must link the two together so let's
have a look
at what they say
proof my name ain't gonna be slim shady
no more so no more slip shady
no more slim shady man because you're
talking if i do come back
you know what my new name will be who's
your man
rain man
[Music]
i sold my soul to the devil i know it
was a crappy deal
pizza came with a few toys like a happy
meal
you know what was going on in my life at
15 and that's how i
got introduced to the music industries i
swear i wanted to be like the amy grand
of music
yeah but it didn't work out and so i
sold my soul to the devil
[Music]
uh how it came about being lyricist is
weird because
i started out technically like i used to
write all the time you know before i
start
uh going into the rain man thing you
know why do you still do it why are you
still out here
well it goes back to the destiny thing
and i made a
bargain with it you know long time ago
and
i'm holding up my hand what was your
bargain
to get where um i am now
should i ask who you made the bargain
with with
with you know with the chief uh chief
commander
on this earth and this earth
and then in the world we can't see i
don't know how
i got to write those songs what do you
mean you don't know how
well those early songs were like almost
magically written try to sit down and
write something like that
uh that there's a magic to that and it's
not
uh sick freedom roy kind of magic you
know it's a
it's a different kind of a penetrating
magic it's right here we call the magic
moment
right now i'm thinking like you know
where is this going what does this track
say
you know i look i look at music like a
puzzle like i try to figure it out
you know figure out what i'm gonna say
on it figure out the emotion and track
what it's saying
then i go through my rain man well
martin what do you say to them
it's obvious with where the inspiration
comes
correct from the rain man it comes from
the rain man
and these people many of them
are knighted and have received
the highest accolades
that very word is part of that ritual
yes you earlier mentioned that they are
role models
there's another word that they can also
come in there that's made
idols idols now how many
of the so-called idols in the world
have gone down the drug road how many
lives have been destroyed because of
drugs and how many people have lost
their lives because of drugs
millions all right now in whose agenda
would that
be something to receive an honor for
definitely the enemy of god
for the enemy of god now a knighthood if
it is an order of chivalry
for service done to the lord
then which lord is being served
it's a question we can ask exactly
as a another quote
jimi hendrix the guitar hero who wrote
the hit song entitled voodoo child
reveals the strength of music as a
medium for setting
atmosphere and indoctrinating minds
he says the blues are easy to play
but not to feel the background to our
music
is a spiritual blues thing
blues is a part of america we're making
our music
into electric church music a new kind of
bible not like in a hotel but the bible
you carry in your hearts
one that will give you a physical
feeling
we try to make our music so loose and
hard-hitting
that it hits your soul hard enough to
make it open
it's like shock therapy or a can
opener rock is technically blues based
we want them to realize that our music
is just as spiritual as going to church
now martin this opening up
to what well to
let some entity help you play
in voodoo they call it the lao a lesser
god
that enters in and possesses you
and in vatican 2 the pope asked that the
spirit
should be able to come in and music is
one can opener that allows him to come
in
interesting that since 1965
musicians have been knighted that's just
after vatican ii
that's just after vatican ii so all of
these things are interconnected
and knighthoods are conferred
for services rendered
[Music]
now we've also noticed
that many of these stars
and celebrities in the world
use certain hand signs now
one shouldn't become too dogmatic on
hand signs
when they are done in a specific format
under very specific circumstances
then there are very distinct messages
the messages with the eyes for example
or this one which is
very deeply in engraved in
in freemasonry yes and also
in view of the the oath of silence
now when it when it becomes a pattern
then you can see there's something
definitely going on
here correct if all the actresses or all
the
musicians every celebrity that you see
have a certain time that they've had a
photo
shoot and this type of
hand signals are pertinently put in
there that's a different thing than
when you sit here and you are busy
talking now if you look at britney
spears for example
one once hot goes out to to people that
are manipulated they start off singing
innocently and they end up having to do
the most weird and horrendous things
and they they have nervous breakdowns
they go
under conservancies as in the case of
britney spears
now here are just some of the photo
shoots that we can see
and a picture of her when she had her
breakdown so she cut off all her hair
and here's a little video just
explaining her situation yeah she's back
in the news again with this whole
conservancy
situation what do we want free
breeding with supporters outside britney
spears spoke to a court for the first
time
publicly about her conservatorship
making bombshell statements about the
rare arrangement under which her father
jamie spears legally controls much of
her life
the singer told the court she wants her
life back wants to end the
conservatorship
and that she didn't know she could
petition the conservatorship to end
spears compared the situation to sex
trafficking
and said she's not here to be anyone's
slave
the conservatorship began in 2008 when
there were concerns over her mental
health
a recent new york times investigation
found that spears expressed
serious opposition to the arrangement
years ago
saying that it restricted everything
from whom she dated to the color of her
kitchen
cabinets i found the most stunning part
of her testimony to relate to
not only how much of her personal life
has been micromanaged
but even the extent to which there's
been medical intrusions into her life
she's being forced into taking a
medication regiment that she doesn't
like
she's being forced to stay on a certain
method of birth control that she doesn't
want to do
and it's really stunning to see that
there's no good reason why a court
should use its process to apply this
sort of a situation upon her personally
from a financial situation
it really is stunning to me that her
father even has
any remote role in this and this will be
really
a learning step for people to see how
this kind of a process
can be used unfortunately in a
potentially abusive manner
basically why we put that in is to show
that these people might seem to be free
but many of them are not free they are
so
enslaved in the system and so
controlled in the system that they
they basically self-destruct in the end
it's a
rather sad state of affairs it is and
and sometimes when they
want to get out of it their lives are
destroyed
they can't and if you take elvis presley
i mean he was a theosophist blavatsky
fan
so these people openly worshipped
satan and where did it take them to a
life
destroyed by drugs and power
you have this moment of power i mean
look at bob dylan look at this
facial expression they
sold themselves to the rain man
and they emptied
themselves whereas christ comes to give
you
life to the full you are
filled with with the freedom
that you cannot express it sets you free
from all the slavery
it is such a sad state of affairs and
like you also mentioned him now
bob dylan one of the reasons he has to
keep going
is because he has to keep his end of the
bargain he has to keep his
end of the bargain and these people
often end up
in the vatican being blessed by the pope
you wonder how do people like bono and
all of these end up at the papal c
they're part of an agenda and the agenda
is to destroy the minds of young people
so that they cannot make right choices
and
we're going to put that quite blatantly
and people might be upset when we say
that
but that is how it is nothing
is as it seems and that is why god
is so adamant about
speaking about this power in rome
as the man of sin
100 absolutely yes because it is the
most destructive power that has ever
existed in the universe you know what
the devil is not there to sympathize
with you
he just wants to use you yes and when
he's finished with you he discards you
yeah so it's not only musicians it's the
whole
palette
so if we look at the stars of this world
angelina jolie for example in 2014
queen elizabeth presented jolie with the
insignia of the honorary dame
grand cross of the most distinguished
order of saint michael
henson george making her an honorary
dame
they always invoke these saints yes
but the saints have subtle undertones
and other meanings that people don't
recognize nothing is as it seems martin
and then you have jakey rowling prince
william appointed rowling as a
companion of honor for literature and
philanthropy in 2017. how many children
have been led down the path of
witchcraft
millions do you get accolades and honors
for
such an activity martin yep it seems you
do
and when you speak about god and you
speak about the bible and righteousness
you get banned you get removed from
youtube
yes you get reprimanded by the pope
you're a conspiracy theorist you're a
conspiracy theorist
i wonder whether these people that label
everything conspiracy
theories shouldn't pay a little bit more
attention and wise up
as to what's happening in the world i
think so it's
in plain sight in plain sight
and sports stars david beckham queen
elizabeth appointed beckham
an officer of the order of the british
empire obe in 2003
we realize of course that sport
is idolatry anything
that takes your mind away
from the true worship is knighted
and receives these honors
yes from the highest hands
benedict cumberbatch received the
commander of the order of the british
empire cbe from queen elizabeth in 2015
and lewis hamilton anything that has to
do
with idolatry correct sports
music any one of these entertainment
jesuit theater let's call it by its name
there they go or what about
nick faldo professional golfer
now you know if you take golf the
gilgamesh epic
the babylonian writings
there when you take a ball
and a stick and the object is to get the
little ball
into a hole or to get a ball
into a net that was celebrated and
the ball is a round object that is a
symbol of the sun
that is celebrated as a victory
of that deity over the powers of
evil now in the occult world
everything is upside down good is called
evil and evil is called good the bible
says
woe to those that call evil god
right yes what is this nighthood all
about
calling evil good calling evil good
right
woe to those that call evil good
so this is part of the gilgamesh epic
whether you kick
a ball into a net whether you take a
stick
to roll a ball into a little hole this
is babylonian religion and if you make
the ball
oblong like in rugby football
then it is a symbol of the cosmic egg
and the way people battle over that
cosmic egg till the blood flows is
amazing
and martin i was such a sports fan in my
day were you a sports fan
i was a sports player as well yes yeah i
played rugby i played
golf well i'm a big fan wow i used to be
a big and now you've become a nerd
my time is being consumed by
another source that's very good
bill gates that gets interesting yeah
right queen elizabeth presented bill
gates with an honorary knighthood in
recognition of his charitable donations
in commonwealth countries in two
thousand and five
i wondered did he receive an itude2 for
destroying the lives of all those indian
children
so i'm wondering why these knighthoods
are being
conferred okay let's look at the order
of
saint john also known as the knights of
malta of course right
that's why their symbol is the maltese
cross
over there in the corner at the top left
so the order of saint john was the first
of a number of religious
military orders established in the
middle
ages at the time when various royal
orders of chivalry
were being established with a code of
conduct focused on
virtues of courage and honor
to these two virtues the order of saint
john added
obedience members of the order swore
religious
oaths that bound them to a shared
purpose
first and foremost they pledged to care
for the sick
and the poor later members trained as
nights for warfare
for this they became known as the
knights hospitalers
they have a very serving front
yes and many a knight of
malta is of course evol
involved in big tech big business
big pharma and pharma is of course
witchcraft right
pharmacia so in the world today
these knights are playing a very
important
role in the economic power
which is basically a military power yes
of the roman
catholic church exactly this is
important because
we'll see in a moment why yes now in
england
these hot hospitals of saint john
are referred to as a protestant order
they don't even change the name
martin if you're going to distantiate
yourself from
from one system like rome yeah wouldn't
you change the name
yes
so the order's motto is pro
fidei pro utilitate
hominem for the faith and the service
of humanity that fits into vatican ii
yup because man is the center right yeah
isn't this service of humanity the
common good
correct this duty of care is just as
relevant today
as it was 900 years ago in jerusalem
so the same emblem as is worn by
the queen here is worn by the catholic
knights yes
so i just want to ask
for the faith and in the service of
humanity and if we say
it links also to the common good so
if they say climate change and
all of these things are for the good of
humanity
then these knights are there to fight
for that
absolutely and they're all very
prominent people
so if we have a look at some people who
have been initiated
into this knighthood then you had nelson
mandela
and desmond tutu now
desmond tutu is very interesting
as a bishop in the anglican church he
didn't believe in a literal
resurrection he didn't believe it at all
in fact most of the tenants of
christianity he denied publicly
and received honors for it so when you
go against what the bible says
then you are honored you are a preacher
correct the next president was taboo
becky
he also was part of the same
order and the order of the bath
the most honorable order of the bath was
established as a
military order by letters patent of
george the first
in the 18th of may 1725
when the dean of westminster was made
dean of the order in perpetuity
and king henry the seventh chapel
designated as the chapel of the order
now martin the order of the bath being a
military order is given to
military men now
the next president of south africa jacob
zuma
was made a member of the order of the
bath because he was the head of
encounter with cesar
which was the military arm of
the present government now it's
fascinating to me
that the high court has now just decided
that jacob zuma has to go to jail yes
and uh i'm wondering what's going to
happen
with this because this is all very
interesting
what is developing in the world today
and there will be people that will be
very upset with that ruling
and i don't know where it's going to
lead to
but let's look so in in 2010 there was a
royal banquet for the south african
president
and the queen made mr zuma an honorary
knight grant cross of the order of the
bath
so it is fascinating to me
that ever since we've had this
turnaround
and we look at the history of a country
like
south africa i always like to look at it
from the religious point of view correct
where are we heading
that's the important part everywhere
where you look back in history
religion played a role right through
correct
this this war is a war against
the religion particularly the religion
of the bible
now i don't want to get involved at all
into in the debates as to
the racial aspects that we've had which
are
very sad and a history that is very sad
but looking behind the scenes as to who
the role players were
they were always masons that is the
important thing because then you will
stop
looking at race yes then you will look
at what's behind
what's going on and how you use the
media
and how you use everything at your
disposal
to portray a certain ideology but what
is the bottom line
what is the end result is
christianity and the religion of the
bible
lifted up or is it trodden down
it's trodden down it's walked over all
right
so ever since we've had these changes
we've brought in paganistic rituals
we've gone back to the ancestral type
of worship that we had and rome is
perfectly happy with it yes like we
showed
they embrace all of them and they
embrace ancestor worship
quite openly in fact they have no choice
because they have all these saints
that they venerate what is that other
than ancestor worship
right so this is the point
this is a war against christianities
and if you take christianity and you
mingle it
with paganism that is the most dangerous
cocktail of all
and in this country where we are
christianity has been merged with
ancestor worship
to such an extent that it is almost
unrecognizable
it is not the bible that is the standard
it is the spirit
that is the standard a very dangerous
concept yes and for all of this you get
knighted
now let's have a look at american
presidents that have been knighted
but let's look at dwight d eisenhower
he was also knighted and he also
received the order of the bath
now that's a military order right as we
have stated for services
rendered to the church in the military
sphere
now let's be quite blatant and quite
plain about this
i think we've established the fact
that the aims the hidden aims of the
church
are not what they appear to the public
there's a dark agenda to remove
the influence of this book
right to destroy protestantism
once and for all and this
war that was fought
under the leadership of eisenhower
was a war that was a military campaign
against protestantism
now i had some lectures and one of them
was called
revolutions tyrants and wars
we don't have to go into all the details
these people were knighted for their
contribution
in the second world war
the entire strong protestant portion of
germany was
cut out and handed over
to an atheistic communist regime yes for
80 years
more or less so that protestantism
could receive its death wound
what about czech republic
all of them all those very strong
christian
today as we've shown in previous
lectures they are the most
secular of all destroyed
services rendered let's give an honorary
knighthood for services
rendered to the destruction of
protestantism
ronald reagan ronald reagan was
very important in the fall of communism
with john paul the ii yes but not only
that
he is the one that again
recognized the papal sea
and he did what no previous president
could do and he opened up the
ambassadorship to
the vatican again healing the rift
between protestantism and catholicism
for these activities and the subsequent
wars yes you receive
an honorary knighthood and those are the
only three presidents that have ever
been knighted yes let's show a little
video
about all the signs and what they mean
and there will be people that criticize
but you know what if something is so
blatant in plain sight maybe people
should be made aware of it once again
yes and here you have the illustrations
of the secret handshakes
look familiar
and this is the sign of the master of
the second veil
see purely masonic
[Music]
you don't pick this stuff up off the
street
now this is how it's generally executed
in the public arena
so when you see this or this
you know for certain where it comes from
and who they belong to
look at kramer on the front page of the
privately circulated freemason magazine
officially a mason like fellow brother
tony abbott
and he's doing this
[Music]
now there will be people that will
heavily criticize what we just
showed and let's say quite
blatantly that not everybody who makes a
sign like this
or like this or puts a hand like this is
necessarily part of the guild
but the fact of the matter of these
these are very very specific
photographs placed in very specific
places
and there are enough indications
to put this beyond the realm of
conspiracy
for instance if you look at that one of
anthony fauci
there is to me without a doubt
that was on purpose absolutely
he was very open about his jesuit
affiliations
yes and these are the people that are
receiving the honors
and the obedience of the entire world
anybody that's going contrary to them
are being ostracized
absolutely let's take them off the
youtube channels
and uh do you really believe martin
that these young people that run
facebook and uh the other
high-tech media google
et cetera et cetera that they really are
such strong personalities that they can
stand up to the entire world
why do they all go and visit the pope
what are they doing there and they had
the big meeting with the pope with
all these big tech and right after that
isn't it
interesting they had that we showed it
last year and just a few weeks or months
after that
all this um banning of
youtube channels and stuff now that the
pope has
asked that these evangelists
be silenced i wonder how that is going
to proceed
well we getting we're getting a small
taste of it
at this stage with this they call it
shadow banning
that's happening on our channel yes
explain
shadow banning to our it's they don't
take off your channel
but your videos don't get recommended
anymore to anybody out there
so your views or whatever the the
publicity of your videos
yes is just shadowed
and somebody can see you unless somebody
shares it but
somebody takes it and share it nobody
else can get it on youtube
and interesting even if just the name
of the presenter is attached to it
it gets blocked in a certain fashion
they've put it into the algorithm for
instance that
if certain names are in the title or
anywhere
then it won't be in the recommended
video sections
interesting isn't it so that is why it's
so
important for our viewers to share
these videos of ours because we're
probably also being put on the
back end of being recommended via videos
correct
and martin that's why it's important
that we
also put all our material
on a server where people can download
yes
put it onto a stick or onto a cd or
whatever
and hand it out i've actually forgotten
about that
because we cannot rely on the media
to continue broadcasting this material
the day will come when they will cut it
off completely
yes but god is amazing how he
opens doors and keeps the message alive
if one removes it another one won't
correct
so he gave us this opportunity he gave
us this opportunity
and i believe this is the message that
the world needs to hear
because we have to make a decision yes
are we going to run with the system
or not and where is this leading to and
why do you receive all these knighthoods
and why do you get accolades for doing
something which is so
blatantly contrary to the word of god
where we're heading for a final clash
correct
for a final clash a clash of minds
and i think it will be a physical clash
as well
there will be arrests there will be
turmoil
and the world is heading for a time of
trouble such as never one yes and we're
going to be looking at that in the next
episode yes this is where the next one
will be on where all of this is heading
correct
and i just want to while you were
mentioning that now that
server that you mentioned we are it's
already we've
advertised it on one of our videos but
also
the links will also be in every single
video that we post in our description
there is a link to our download server
you can go and download
all our videos for free you have to push
that show more right
otherwise you don't get it yes on the
description
there's a button that says show more on
your phone you just have to go and ask
somebody to show you where you see the
description of a video
martin let's end with a reliable source
this comes from the book evangelism page
617.
there are those who question whether it
is right for christians
to belong to freemasons and other secret
societies
let all such consider the scriptures
just quoted
about the confederacy confederacy in the
book of isaiah
if we are christians at all we must be
christians
everywhere and must consider and heed
the council given to make us christians
according to the standard of god's word
in our connection with worldly societies
are you keeping your covenant with god
do these associations tend to direct
your mind
or that of others to god or are they
diverting the interest and attention
from him do they strengthen your
connection with the divine agencies
or turn your mind to the human in place
of the divine
while there may be in these society much
that appears to be good
there is mingled with this very much
that makes the good of no effect
and renders these associations
detrimental to the interests of the soul
that is the reality of the matter
now in my entire life i've been steeped
in this kind of world view
and i'm so grateful to god
that he has placed this book
into my hands and the strange thing is i
always had it in my hands
but only to mock it and ridicule it
but to find that i have been duped by
the world
and by these systems and to discover
that this is the only reality worth
serving
has made a big change in my life and i
can see
that it's made a big change in your life
right martin correct
it's important because if you didn't
let god use that book
then it wouldn't have changed you i
wouldn't have changed i was a christian
in name but i had to let god
show me what is not right and i want to
be willing to change it
you have to be willing to change it yes
and you have to be willing to make that
the standard of your life
and if you make that the standard of
your life then all of this deception
will be exposed correct and you will
distance yourself
from it people are saying why are you
looking at these things
excuse me billions are being taken to
the
down the path of perdition by
exactly what we've been discussing over
here
and there is no incentive if you don't
show the error of that way to turn to
the truth
correct we've shown through this whole
series
we've covered every spectrum of life
from the political to the religious
everywhere rome is intertwined in it
perhaps the last word an appeal
to christian institutions in the world
not to run along with this stream
and further it as though it were a
system of truth
it is a system of lies masquerading as
truth
the only truth that we have is
the truth the way the life
and the words that he has pinned through
his prophets
and his servants throughout the ages
let's cling
to the word of god as the only safety
because we are almost at
the harbour let's pray
heavenly father there's so much
deception in the world out there
and anybody who in the remotest way
contributes to the destruction of your
word and your truth seems to be honored
by the world
with great accolades lord
let there be no accolades but let there
be truth
in our lives in jesus name amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe to our channel
click here to get notifications click on
the bell
to watch the next video click here
thank you and we'll see you again